a mis espaldas está el río nieve y en
esta parte linda con lo que es la presa
de kahooca que fue destruida el pasado 6
de junio de allí que en este momento el
cauce del río no tenga nada de agua y al
otro lado del río está la planta nuclear
de saporilla la más grande de Europa y
que está en este momento en control de
las fuerzas rusas están esta población
de narcodar que está al frente de
nicopol y Desde allí es atacada
constantemente esta ciudad de nicopor lo
que suma ya La amenaza que tiene lo que
pueda pasar con esta planta nuclear
especialmente desde la destrucción de la
presa esta fue esta planta nuclear fue
visitada días atrás por el secretario
general de la organización internacional
de energía atómica de Rafael grossia
gran preocupación por lo que pueda pasar
en ella ahora que el agua ha bajado y no
se puedan refrescar
esta planta nuclear él ha dicho que hay
agua suficiente en la reserva por
algunas meses que la situación es
bastante seria y seis de esas Torres
están en este momento apagadas una de
ellas solamente funciona un nivel
bastante bajo para dar energía a esta
planta nuclear pero esta situación crea
mayor amenaza a la población que todavía
permanece en esta ciudad de Nicole que
sumado al peligro y a las dificultades
Ahora tiene que vivir sin agua y con el
olor que viene del río que está ahora
seco